you know when it comes to just longevity
in the rap game not a lot of people have
longevity not people can
support themselves for the amount of
time that you've been able to do so you
know like you got to know how to rap
hustle
rap hustle break that down
um
doing like everything that comes around
rap
if it's verses if it's videos if it's
um
you know different people endorse you
like you got to know how to really get
off your ass and get to it like a lot of
people just be content
and just sit back and you know like okay
so really
i kind of like i seen jim one night we
was out
jim jones yeah okay and he was like um
he had like three different shows did
like four verses in one night and like
one guy was like for ten
ten twenty thousand another guy went
over there and had like 7500 like he
wasn't turning down nothing just getting
running it over this not saying that he
was doing the same amount of work for
the
for the lower but he wasn't turning down
nothing so you got to get up and rap
hustle yeah i think like if you're
independent and
you know there's definitely like
there's a way to just super monetize
what you're doing yeah and then you know
we're rapping all type of different
things come like um chelsea just hit me
right now and red bull want me to do
something
uh
like a freestyle on the block mm-hmm and
uh they supposed to be paying me for it
or whatever then i i just started doing
the cameo thing to where you do all you
go on cameo and people can like you know
if they want to if you want to do a drop
for you or like a happy birthday for you
so it's like so many different
opportunities that rap bring to you that
you can you know hustle
yeah i think that a lot of artists leave
money on the table yeah a lot of people
because if you're just depending on i
never wanted to do that at first like
the
shout out stuff right i never did it in
one day i'm like let me see i think i
made like three thousand and one more
cameo no now off cameo i just started
doing some my
if someone like says hey phil yes i want
to pay you pay my shout out my store
yeah and then at first i never was doing
that [ __ ] like i seen a lot of rappers
doing that [ __ ] through the pandemic
boozy be doing that [ __ ]
i'm like man let me see somebody was
like hey man i give you 500 posters in
the story for me
my cash happened to me he sent it i
posted i'm like oh there's something
here yeah but i never i've they've been
asking me to do i give you 2 000 to post
me on your page i'm like hell night
posting on my page
i'm like i just think that there's like
a stigma that i think is probably like
not
accurate in terms of like
you know i think there's certain artists
that like that might not make sense for
if you're if you're like the weekend or
you're like but if you're an independent
artist and you're sure you should be
doing it you should be running it up man
listen that [ __ ] it's good luck
right now and already got like two of
them already sent